كانت ليله الثامن من يناير ثقيله في
برازيليا راويه ذكرت بيوم مشابه لمحصل في
واشنطن هجوم منسق على الكونجرس رفضا
لنتائج الانتخابات هجوم غذاه الرئيس
السابق الخاسر يائيل البطسونارو بسنطه
الهجوم المنسق قاده انصار بون سونارو على
مبنى المحكمه العليا والكونغرس والقصر
الرئاسي غطينا ذلك باخبار عاجله بالامس
وبفيديوهات وصلتنا للتو مشهد ذكر باقتحام
مبنى الكابتل من قبل الانصار الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في السادس
من يناير عام 20 21 لم يلبس الرئيس
البرازيلي الخاسر ببنت شفافه بعد الهزيمه
لكنه ودعاء انصاره قبل ان يغادر الى
فلوريدا بالدموع مصرا على ان احتيالا تم
لسلبه الرئاسه لكن وعقب الهجوم على رموز
السياده البرازيليه اليوم دانابول سوناربو
بالامس دانابول سونار اعمال العنف العاصمه
لكنها نصف نعم
وقد وجد من خلالها طريقه ايضا لانتقاد
خصومه مره جديده كتب على تويتر يقول بعد
ساعات من بدء الهجوم ان التظاهرات السلميه
جزء من الديمقراطيه بموجب القانون ومع ذلك
فان اعمال النهب والغزو للمباني العامه
كما حدث اليوم عندما كتب ذلك وكذلك تلك
التي مارسها اليسار في عام 2013
و2017 كانت خارج القانون اذا شبهها
بتظاهرات اليسار السابقه
[موسيقى]
عقب ساعات من الهجوم تمت استعاده السيطره
على مقار السلطه البرازيليه لتطلق السلطات
القضائيه تحقيقات اوليه لتحديد المسؤوليات
في الهجوم بعدما تفقدها الرئيس الحالي
لويس اناسيو لودا سيلفا بعدما تفقد
المباني منجدا بما قام بهم او بهم
انقلابيون كما سماهم الرئيس اليسرى كتب في
تغريده على تويتر يجري التعرف على
الانقلابيين الذين اقدموا على تخريب
الممتلكات العامه في برازيليا وسيحاسبون
سنستانف العمل في قصر رونالدو الديمقراطيه
دائما
وقف اكثر من 300 شخص وطالبت النيابه
العامه بفتح تحقيقات فوريه لتحديد مسؤوليه
المتورطين في الهجوم على المباني الرسميه
تلك وقد طوقت سلطات المنطقه قال احد
المتظاهرين ويدعى فيكتور رودريغيز نحن لا
نعترف بهذه الحكومه لانها غير قانونيه
واضاف لن نتراجع سنرحل من هنا لكننا سنعود
[موسيقى]
اللافته ان المتظاهرين استمر بترديد هتاف
تدخل عسكري لطرد لولا من الحكم وهنا
استحضر حديثا سابقا للرئيس السابق
بوتسونارو حين قال في سبتمبر 20 21 ان
الصبر الشعب قد نفذ اريد ان اخبر اولئك
الذين يريدون ان يجعلوني غير قابل
للانتخاب في البرازيل الله وحده يبعدني عن
السلطه لدي ثلاثه خيارات او الموت او
النصر
جديده
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في معهد البحوث
فونتشا
وهو يعير نيكولا
لقد اشار الى
ان من اتباعه الاكثر الجيولوجيه انه
يدعمهم وانهم يفعلون ما لا يستطيع رئيسهم
الكبير القيامه به كان صمته الشراره
الرئيس التي اشعلت الاحتجاجات التي تحدث
الان لكن الاكيد ان محاسبتهم قائمه وزير
العدل البرازيلي
والاعتقالات في حاله التلبس مستمره لانه
عمليا
او بعد ذلك بوقت قصير